one of the networks you know that was  enforcement mechanisms of the past in  fact mentioned by the founding fathers  in the Constitution was that this was a  constitution that was wholly unfit for a  non-god-fearing population in other  words God you know fearing in their  nature was essential even the ones that  were a deist or even atheists of the  founding fathers and so they implemented  something which would seem to be sort of  uh subjective and hard to implement in  the purely cryptographic or chain-based  reality when you could do everything  with  50.000 per point one percent consensus  and that was the Electoral College and  obviously there's lots of moves to get  rid of that but that's you know wholly  effectively uh meant to undo the tyranny  of the majority I wonder is there room  in a network state for those four  different you know kind of Concepts or  previous Concepts to still do useful  work